hey uh does cancel culture actually
exist in light of the latest right wing
cancellation of the new M Ms we have to
talk about cancel culture does cancel
culture actually exist someone sent me
an article from the center on a
stateless society uh which is sort of
the the basis for this segment and that
article really got me thinking and what
I mean by does cancel culture really
exist is sometimes things are canceled
in the sense that people are fired or a
Show is canceled or someone is
ostracized or people change their views
or activists Express opinions that say I
don't like what you said that happens
right that takes place but does the
cancel culture that Republicans describe
actually exist Does this culture exist
when Republicans scream we are being
canceled by the woke left I believe that
it does not really exist often what is
happening is that someone's words or
actions are having consequences as those
words and actions are being evaluated in
the free market of ideas which
Republicans claim to support oftentimes
the canceled still have a bully pulpit
plenty of access to corporate media
social media and other platforms to
spread their views sometimes they're
quote canceled in the sense that they
lose when they're entertainers they lose
one opportunity but then they come back
and they get another opportunity and
sometimes it takes a little while you
look at Mel Gibson who had this horrible
incident where he was pulled over drunk
driving and he said to the officer are
you a Jew and I I guess the officer was
Jewish you know what are the odds
um and then he you know made all sorts
of other horrible statements and there
was a period during which Mel Gibson
wasn't doing much work in Hollywood but
like then he's back then he started
getting work again and so is that is
that really a cancellation there was a
period during which his statements and
actions impacted his career it seems
logical that in such a free market there
are consequences to the things that you
say and that you do and so often and
this is really what I believe is at the
Crux of this meme of cancel culture that
the right likes to talk about often
those who are accused of doing the
canceling are people from groups that
only more recently are getting a louder
voice they are from previously
marginalized groups and thanks to social
media and the internet some of those
individuals some of those groups are now
having more of a voice to express their
views people speak out and they push
back against marginalization and
sometimes there are consequences to the
person doing the marginalizing and now
they have been canceled as if it's bad
that there are consequences for the
things that they have said or done now
it's also worth noting that by their own
definition
of canceling it is often Republicans
that are doing the canceling despite the
fact that they say it's the left that
does the canceling and we see this in
the way that they try to silence
descending voices in the media and in
Academia and in politics they want to
control the narrative they want to shut
down voices that challenge their
ideology and when they get called out
they say it's cancer culture as a way to
deflect responsibility and to play the
victim everything they accuse the left
of the doing they do let me remind you
of something else this isn't as popular
in the last couple of years but you used
to often hear from the right
saying you're offended isn't an argument
and I agreed with them right if someone
makes a statement and someone on the
left or the right responds by saying
that's offensive
boom Conversation Over
I think that that is a way to shut down
an argument to shut down debate and it's
not actually an argument in and of
itself you've offended me boom well
let's let's talk about what I said let's
talk about why why okay
that's cancel culture
is exactly the same thing it is exactly
equivalent to I'm offended and the
conversation oh that's cancel culture
that's it no we're done it's exactly the
same thing now
let I'll be upfront with everybody here
you all know I am not blind to the
reality that sometimes people may go too
far in their activism sometimes the
calls for someone's head are premature
or they are inappropriate if we go back
and think about by the way when
Democrats demanded that their own
Senator Al Franken resign Al Franken
participated in a tasteless joke that
was photographed and it was tasteless
there's no question about it but in a
sense Democrats were too quick to say
you got to resign Al Franken partially
because Democrats wanted to show how how
fair and nonpartisan they were when it
came to these things and the reality is
that what Al Franken did was really
quite minor compared to the things
others have gotten away with so I'm not
blind to the fact that sometimes people
go too far but that doesn't mean you
can't hold anyone accountable and if you
do it's cancel culture so we need to
shift from calling people out to
uh it's so cliche like sometimes that
people say we need to call people in to
talk right this is all the reality of
there are now many more platforms on
which people can speak
and there are many more platforms on
which people can respond to speech and
so that's the reality and so the idea of
cancel culture is this monolithic
movement to silence people is basically
meaningless it's not accurately
representing what's happening there's no
conspiracy it's the marketplace of ideas
that the right holds up
as a place where ideas or jokes or
bigotry or ad campaigns or content or
whatever are open to criticism and
they're open to consequences so let's
get away from the term cancel culture I
use it tongue-in-cheek when I say look
it's cancel culture from the right but
it's really a political Boogeyman and
it's meant to silence voices often
marginalize voices it's meant to protect
the status quo particularly when it
comes to Republicans by making them
immune to the consequences of their
actions and their words don't fall for
it let's actually push back against the
concept of cancel culture